imagine you're in a spacesuit drifting
away from the Sun rather than dwell on
how you ended up here open the pod bay
doors Hal I'm sorry Derek I'm afraid I
can't do that wait you you decide to
collect data for your Google science
fair project
you notice that as you move further away
from the Sun the intensity of its light
decreases and this isn't due to the
light dying away or being absorbed it's
simply due to the light energy being
spread over more space consider the
light emitted by the Sun in a single
second it's not energy to power the
whole world for a million years or to
heat up three thousand two hundred
billion billion hot pockets as all that
light travels out through space you can
think of it spreading out over the
surface of a growing sphere and since
the surface area of a sphere is four PI
R squared the intensity of light is
inversely proportional to the square of
distance from the Sun so when you're
twice as far away is where you started
the light will be a quarter as bright
and this is known as the inverse square
law so as you continue past the Pluto
formally known as a planet the light
becomes dimmer and dimmer until it is so
faint that you can't even see the Sun
well that's not terribly surprising but
what if you had really sensitive eyes
like the eyes of a frog well then as you
move further away from the Sun by the
inverse square law you would expect to
see the light decreasing in brightness
but never fading out completely but that
is not what you see at some point the
Sun begins to flicker so you see flashes
of light
separated by complete darkness and
what's weirder as you continue to move
further away the flashes would not
decrease in brightness instead they
merely become less frequent
if you took the average of the flashes
and darkness you would find it smoothly
follows the curve of the inverse square
law but the light itself comes in lumps
they are indivisible and so they can't
get any less intense only more spread
out this dramatically demonstrates that
light is quantized meaning it always
comes in multiples of a smallest
quantity called a quantum incredible
you're making the slit narrower and yet
the spot on the wall is getting wider
the narrower you make it the wider that
spot on the wall becomes to understand
this we have to look at Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle can you think of
some other things that are quantized
please put them in the comments and say
what a single quantum of that thing is
I'm sorry Derek I'm afraid I can't do
that for example cash money is quantized
and a quantum of money is a penny unless
you live in Australia in which case
we've got rid of pennies so the smallest
division is 5 cents but now a lot of
machines won't even take 5 cents so we
should probably get rid of that - ok
what other things can you think of